some years ago
this uh uh little town became famous for
uh having uh five centenarians that made
it to the the cover of national
geographic i mean five centenarians out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is a blue zone these are regions of the
world where people live much longer and
healthier than the average
the oldest person recorded here was
salvatore caruso he's what you'd call a
super centenarian having made it to 110.
he passed away in 2015 but not before
assisting those in search of eternal
youth
i think salvatore has been an
inspiration right to to say well i
followed this this person for the last
50 years of his life or so
and he made it to 110 healthy so
i've seen 110 healthy i've seen it with
him but it's not going to be doable for
the the entire world population it's
going to be doable i think for the
people that listen and follow all the
right moves
walter longo has spent the past two
decades identifying the optimum foods
and fasting practices for living
healthier and longer
now he's preparing for his largest human
study to date here in a remote italian
town famous for centenarians
this clinical trial that was just funded
by the european community it's going to
take 500 people and it's going to split
them into two and it's going
allow half of them to sort of have the
the bad modern habits
now that are very different from those
of the centenarians so we take half of
them and we let them
be have this western-like diet and we
take the other half and we bring him
back to the longevity diet
longo created the longevity diet by
combining scientific research and lab
work with the study of centenarians
around the world
[Music]
[Music]
longo will also be testing his fasting
mimicking diet which offers the benefits
of prolonged fasting without having to
actually fast
fasting has been done for thousands of
years of course but we now have to move
away again from from the uh these ideas
words like eating or fasting they bought
mean
very little
and move into exactly what do we eat and
how do we fast
so it shouldn't be about you know now
we're going to turn everybody into a
biohacker
and use technology and distort
everything
instead we should learn from the past
and unite that with the science
[Music]
i plan to discuss with you what i
believe to be the most profoundly
transformational concept and strategy as
it pertains to health and aging so is
this is this your first meal of the day
it's now almost six o'clock uh it will
be yeah because well because it's clear
based on thousands of years of human
existence that uh eating less is if it's
not starvation or malnutrition it's good
for you because why yesterday i started
this thing called
intermittent fasting
which is everybody's doing it fasting is
such
an interesting part of the longevity
conversation
we've looked at cultures where fasting
is a practice right where there's ritual
fasting and ask the question of well why
are these people living so long
so
we know that fasting does kick off
certain biological processes that seem
to also have a connection to longevity
what we don't know at this point is how
long do you have to fast does it work
for everyone or are there just certain
people with certain genetics for whom
that works so there's still a lot of
questions but at this point it
definitely does appear
that restricting what you eat
might have some impact on how long you
live and how healthy you are
intermittent fasting time restricted
feeding and calorie restriction are just
some of the popular methods being
adopted
and while cutting down on meals has long
been viewed as a weight loss hack it's
increasingly being practiced as a
measure to delay the aging process and
stave off chronic diseases that
accompany it
studies have shown it has the potential
to protect against a range of
age-related diseases diabetes heart
disease and cognitive decline to name a
few
but one hurdle remains
very few people want to do it have you
done it yourself
i've done it myself yes i've fasted for
for four days
several times and to me it was very
tough
longo began his research in the early
90s identifying the genes associated
with aging and how nutrients affect them
longo tested different fasting methods
and their effect on longevity in
organisms ranging from yeast to mice to
humans
he found that cycles of fasting and
refeeding cause multi-system
regeneration enhance cognitive
performance and the potential to prevent
and treat disease
it's hard to imagine something that will
do more to a person than fasting if you
look at gene expression so if you look
at the how the genes are activated or
not one of the key mechanisms at play is
a process known as autophagy which
literally means self-eating
during autophagy cells destroy viruses
and bacteria and get rid of damaged
structures in order to regenerate newer
healthier cells
damaged cells can speed up aging and
lead to cancer if they're not destroyed
so this process is vital to health and
lifespan
the best known way to activate autophagy
in humans is fasting we started with
water only fasting and and we started
with a cancer trial um using water only
fasting and we thought of course you
know somebody has cancer they're gonna
be motivated to to do this and they're
not gonna have a problem with five days
of water only fasting
but we were wrong so it was the u.s
government that eventually and the
national cancer institute and eventually
the national institute and aging the
funded research for the fasting making
diet
longo created the fasting mimicking diet
or fmd a meal plan that's formulated to
stimulate a fasting state while
providing nutrients and calories through
small amounts of food the fasting making
diet is a high fat low protein low sugar
low calorie diet and starts with 1100
kilocalories on day one and it drops to
about 800 kilocalories on day two three
four five usually between 70 percent to
90 compliant so most people don't have a
problem doing this once a month or so
for a number of cycles
the fmd's calorie restriction mimics the
body's physiological response to
traditional fasting methods
but it's not as simple as just
restricting calories
longo and his team spent years
perfecting nutrient combinations that
can be consumed without triggering the
body's food sensing pathways you place a
system on a fasting medicine diet and
the system starts to shrink and what
we're seeing is that the damage
components are being removed first
and then we thought well if this fasting
mimicking diet preferentially kills
damaged components rebellious components
is it possible that it'll go after the
cancer cells the autoimmune cells the
insulin resistant cells for the past 10
years we've been focusing on that and
and finding that
they do
while longo and his team see promising
results among patients suffering from a
variety of diseases he stresses the fmd
is not an alternative to drugs
instead it works most effectively in
combination with them i think that the
doctor of the future is going to need to
know a lot more about these and
especially now that in the united states
uh healthcare costs are approaching
about 20 percent of of the of the gdp
so this is not sustainable and and food
obviously is the best way to go
having gone through 30 clinical trials
the fmd is in the process of getting fda
approval for cancer now
we have just gone to the fda
and filed what's called an indeed so to
make food into a drug right so how can
food
be now used for for cancer patients
longer has developed a meal delivery
service called prolon which people can
buy the meals for the fmd
and he recommends speaking to a medical
professional before starting
he says he donates all his profits from
prolonged to research
well
first of all i think volta is wrong
but he and i have always disagreed on
pretty much everything david sinclair is
another heavyweight in the field of
longevity
and represents the conflict that still
exists within this scientific community
while the pair agree on the biological
mechanisms at play during a fasting
state they disagree on which are most
important and the best way to activate
them there's one thing i would recommend
in midlife to do that could extend your
lifespan it's fasting we find my
colleagues and i find that
it's not so much how much you eat and
what you eat it's when you eat
and uh so you don't don't always be fed
don't always give in to those hunger
pains i drink i drink tea and i actually
don't eat probably till late lunch or
dinner every day as a way to get those
body defenses going every day
on an average day sinclair fasts for 22
hours eating just one large meal he
encourages long daily fasts to instigate
a biological process called hermesis
homasis is the adaptive response of
cells and organisms when the body is put
under moderate stress
short bursts of stress such as fasting
stimulate the body's mitochondria which
convert food and oxygen into energy for
cells to use
the body's mitochondria play a crucial
role in supporting major organs but its
functionality decreases with age
hormesis has been found to improve the
mitochondrial performance therefore
improving life and health span
these processes that we're studying
these
basically enhancing our own innate
defenses against disease they exist
within us and we don't need medicines to
turn them on we can
skip a meal we can become exhausted from
running we can lift weights we can eat
the right foods focus on plants this
kind of stuff and we actually know
just like
epidemiologists have figured out that
these are the things you can do to
enhance those
defenses
while longo acknowledges the role of
hormesis he suggests there may be
downsides to this kind of fasting for
example now we know that if you fast
every day for 16 hours and then involves
keeping breakfast that can actually be
negative for you
in the long run and there is association
with a reduced lifespan we also know
that if you fast for too long your
metabolism can slow down which
may make it difficult for you to
maintain a lower
weight
while experts in the field may disagree
on specifics they're all agreed on one
thing
disinformation around fasting is a major
concern it's unfortunate 99 of what's
out there is is complete rubbish
and uh so what i'm trying to do
as a service is to speak to the public
and say there is this group of
scientists who are publishing the
world's top journals
that really are making progress in this
area and while we don't have anything to
prescribe just yet
it is coming soon and certainly there
are things you can do in your lifestyle
with your lifestyle that'll get you
ready for when those come
longo hopes his upcoming trial can move
the conversation along
the 18-month study in malocchio will
split 501 participants aged 30 to 65
into three groups
one will be a control group so keep
their usual diet
one keeps their diet and has three
cycles for fmd the final will be
following the daily longevity diet
the longevity diet is more a lifestyle
so it's an everyday diet and this is
mainly vegan but not only vegan because
you find also
the fish
especially small fishes so
avoiding
the accumulation of mercury for example
which is neurotoxic and there are also
some
fasting periods for example the
overnight fasting which is around 12
hours and this is very important to
improve metabolism and to connect with
the circadian rhythm
all participants will be followed by
nutritionists like sevigny who will
monitor and review their biomarkers
in order to define the best diet it is
important to put together a lot of
information both
from scientific field but also from the
population so you in this way
you can test the information that comes
from science
in the feasibility so
which of the informations that come from
science
can be applied in everyday life
so i think that as we change our idea of
what it means to be healthy and look
instead
uh you know what are the the biometric
signals of health you know what's your
blood pressure stuff like that we're
gonna see more emphasis
on getting people to eat foods that are
good for you and to exercise than just
you know asking people to lose weight so
they can be healthier
[Music]
huge discoveries have been made in the
field of longevity and nutrition over
the past two decades but it's still
early days
most research has been done in cells and
animals and while this has provided
early clues to how periods without food
may affect the human body it will be the
clinical trials that offer the most
insight into how we can reach 100
healthy
yesterday for me was the first time i
met centenarian and
i
realized what longevity means
so living long but being healthy and
being present
be happy with your family and
i think
if diet can help
reaching longevity in this way
it's really worth it
equally
okay
you